there's a video that I 100 legitimately
play in my mind when I'm tired I say
good listen to this video have you ever
heard this it's amazing he would call me
up or pull me aside with some major
problems some issue that was going on
and he'd say boss we got this and that
the other thing and I look at him and
I'd say good
and finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and he said I already know what
you're gonna say
I said well what am I going to say he
said you're going to say good
I said that's what you always say when
something is wrong and going bad you
always just look at me and say good
and I said well yeah when things are
going bad
there's going to be some good that's
going to come from it didn't get the new
high speed gear we wanted good didn't
get promoted
good more time to get better